Aloha my name is Bree and I work at
Airbnb big changes at big organizations
is hard there's a lot of people to
convince and a lot of code to migrate
I'd like to share with you how we
brought typescript to Airbnb I
appreciate you all being here with me I
know you could be out at the beach with
your snazzy new towel but I hope there's
something in here for everyone whether
you're navigating a big change at your
company and this could be used as a sort
of case study whether you're actively
migrating to typescript now and there
are tools and techniques that we'll talk
about that can help or if you've heard a
bit about typescript and want to learn
more first we'll cover what typescript
is what we mean by at scale the process
of proposing typescript at this scale
addressing questions and concerns along
the way in response to the proposal how
we gradually adopted typescript and
migration strategies that we're using to
move from JavaScript to typescript by a
quick show of hands how many people have
used typescript before oh cool that's a
big number of you not everybody raise
our hands so let's give a quick
introductions so that everybody is on
the same page
suppose we had this greeter function it
takes a name and returns hello that name
so if we pass it in J's cough it would
say hello J's cough how friendly here's
what that code would look like in
typescript notice that it's quite
similar the only difference is that
we've annotated the parameter with what
type it is
so if we use this function in our
typescript project and we pass a string
everything compiles fine but if we pass
something that's not a string in this
case an array of strings typescript will
give us an error that a string array is
not assignable to a parameter of type
string we didn't have to refresh the
page click through our flow look at the
error in our console and trace back
through where the error happened we got
this era immediately in our editor right
after we typed it we can express the
type of other objects as well
this interface describes a shape of a
person object that has a first name and
a last name and you can describe types
for more complicated constructs
typescript normally comes with a
compiler that can tell you when
something has gone wrong it also has a
language server that editors can hook
- for things like auto-completion find
usages for factoring and more in this
example we've hooked up the type for our
with styles react higher cut order
component so we get autocomplete for the
hundreds of CSS properties it accepts
including inline documentation amazing I
didn't have to flip back and forth to
the docs pages I got all of this in my
editor with types with types throughout
our code we can do more as it's being
authored this just scratches the surface
of what typescript is capable of but
gives you a sense of the kind of areas
that can help catch and the tooling it
enables so that's the typescript part
what about the at scale part Oh is there
a problem oh thanks tied scripts I'm not
actually making all this up if you did
typo a variable that would give you an
area that looked like that so it
actually is real thing so let's fix that
so the scale changes a conversation I've
been on small teams before where it was
just hey you wanna use typescript yeah
sounds cool let's use it but as you
scale up to hundreds of engineers and
more and more code that conversation
changes we would have changed that we
were proposing is using typescript in
our main repo the one that powers
airbnb.com
and making it a primary language for
front-end development more people are
affected by the change and more code
would have to be migrated let's quantify
what we mean by at scale an error maybe
we have lots of JavaScript there's over
two billion lines with JavaScript
checked into our main repo and over 100
internal NPM packages these are separate
repos that we've packaged up to an
internal NPM registry that we can share
across repos
that's a lot of code we still got some
backbone in there talk about Shaun's
history of JavaScript we got some
history over the the Airbnb decade so we
we also have lots of Engineers
interacting with this code there are
over 1300 at the company 200 of which
are fronting the majority of these
front-end engineers contribute to that
main mono repo those numbers paint a
picture of the environment in which we
were proposing typescript and what did
it what did it look like at that scale
every month we have a fun meeting where
all the front-end
engineers around the company get
together and we geek out about new
front-end technologies and patterns for
things we want to consider in more depth
we draft proposals that outline things
like benefits trade-offs alternatives
considered exit strategy and long-term
owners people weigh in on the pros and
cons of these proposals and we decided
as a group whether it makes sense to
move forward this ensures we make
deliberate decisions about what we
commit to as a broader team and avoid
hopping on the hype train without
legitimate technical justification we've
been exploring typescript at Airbnb
since 2016 on smaller teams and a static
type system was a top request from a
20-17 front end survey given this
positive signal Joe and I shout out to
Joe second row there we drafted a
proposal for typescript and presented it
to the front end working group the
proposal detailed why typescript made
sense at Airbnb let's highlight some of
the main reasons everybody's mission is
to make it so anyone can belong anywhere
every issue a user encounters with our
product gets in the way of that mission
the same is true of the products you all
are working on typescript helps prevent
bugs which in turn helps our end users
typescript also enables a wealth of
developer productivity benefits and
tooling like editor auto completion and
refactoring like we saw earlier with
typescript engineers can move faster
more safely we're investing in graph QL
and Apollo at Airbnb which lets us
generate typescript types from our graph
ul schemas this means that we can get
end to end size type safety because the
types used by the back end and the front
end share a single source of truth a
back-end engineer can make a change to
the API without unknowingly breaking
clients and front-end engineers can be
confident about what data will be coming
back from the server type mismatches
have been a major source of bugs for us
so this end-to-end type safety was a
major selling point sounds great right
but there were lots of questions and
concerns in response to our initial
proposal let's look at a few of them in
more depth
our mono repo depends on our internal
NPM packages do we need to convert those
to typescript first in order to get
autocomplete and type checking
so this is the predicament we have we
have our tiger project that depends on a
jsm PM package how do we get types for
that package it would seem like the
package needs to be converted to
typescript first
but that's problematic because we be
blocked on the maintainer converting it
and maybe they're reluctant to do so
because at the early phases of our
proposal it wasn't sure we were going to
move forward with it but on the flip
side in order for developers to have a
good experience with typescript we
needed that type safety so how do we get
around the seeming chicken and egg
problem
typescript has a feature called
declaration files files with a DTS
extension which we can define types for
JavaScript files let's look at an
example so we have the greeter function
that we saw earlier and the
corresponding DTS file on the top there
are no implementation details here it
only describes what the types are
typescript stitches these together such
that the Declaration file is used at
compile time and the original JavaScript
is used at runtime so let's go back to
our original scenario and see how
declaration files can help sure if that
project had been converted to typescript
we couldn't generate a DDS file as part
of the typescript build but we were
considering that that wasn't an option
so instead we could put the declaration
file in our typescript project another
choice is that we can create a separate
NPM package and put the declaration
files there this is nice because now we
can share the declaration files across
several repos and this is how types for
things like react work you have a you
install react and you can install a
types react package the types for react
along with those for 5,000 other
packages live indefinitely types a
community maintained repository the vast
majority of public dependencies we had
in our main repo were already typed and
definitely typed the active community
around typescript was a major selling
point and we've contribute back I'm sure
they're people around this room that
have contributed back thank you
type definitely typed works great for
public NPM packages but what about the
internal ones we mirrored this
definitely type setup internally by
creating a separate NPM scope so instead
of installing from types you did install
from Airbnb types
and the repo is set up similar to how
definitely type is so we could add our
types there and publish these types
internally and we've open-sourced a
starter kit if you are interested in
setting up this sort of thing it doesn't
have any types in it it's more just the
setup for how you can add tests and
publish your own types how many bugs can
typescript help prevent a recent study
to type or not to type show that 15% of
bugs in a selection of github repos were
preventable with typescript internally
we have a process for documenting
incidents that occur in production this
is a blameless process the point is so
that we can learn from our mistakes so
we don't repeat them in the future so I
literally sat down and read through six
months worth of post mortems super-fun
reading right so my favorites like tale
of the uncut type error the peril of the
per muted parameters okay maybe they
didn't have such exciting names in any
case I categorize them as JavaScript
related or not and determine which of
those could have been prevented with
typescript let's look at example where
typescript would have helped we made a
change to our shared input component
that broke a form on a settings page
users were unable to submit the form
because it no longer passed validation
here is a simplified version of that
shared and can put component before the
change it takes an on blur prop and
passes it straight through to the input
element a change was made to add a new
in on blur handler but there was a
subtle bug can you spot it the event
parameter was no longer being passed to
the on blur prop this caused an issue
several hops away in a different repo
the input component was being consumed
as part of a redux form which expects an
event or value to be passed in order for
the validation to work properly without
the event the form no longer pass
validation which meant the submit button
was always disabled
how could typescript have helped us here
the types for redux form capture the
constraint we saw in the docs the on
blur prop must be passed an event
value so if we had been using typescript
with Redux form types hooked up we would
have seen an error at the call site
where the event wasn't being passed
another common class of issues involved
strict mill checks where you use a
property to structure or try to invoke
something that could be null or
undefined you've probably seen that one
before
another was type mismatches typescript
tells us when we try to use types that
are not assignable to one another so now
that we have a better sense of the
common kinds of post-mortem bugs
typescript can help prevent what's the
overall percentage 38% we found that 38%
of incident causing bugs that reach
production bugs that have real effects
on our users and bottom line could have
been prevented with typescript
this was a huge finding for us it helped
make the impact real we saw light bulbs
go off as we replicated some of the
incidents and showed people the arrow
type script would have given sure we
could have written tests to catch these
sort of things but static type checking
adds an extra layer of protection so if
you access to a similar history at your
company it could be worth taking a look
with someone who knows typescript to see
what this percentage looks like for you
do teams want to switch to typescript we
pilot a typescript on several teams
specifically targeting teams that hadn't
used typescript before to gain
additional perspective we help them get
set up and gather feedback along the way
after using it for a while we sent a
survey to them asking whether we should
continue investing in typescript and the
feedback was overwhelmingly positive
we'd recommend using this sort of trial
period for testing out a new technology
or pattern the front-end working group
was on board with it because it was
self-contained and it was easy to
rollback should we not move forward with
it and it helped the proposal because we
could gauge whether teams actually liked
using typescript there were concerns
around build times we measured it and
found no significant impact we have over
500 e eslint rules enabled in our main
repo with the typescript eslint parser
we were happy to discover that most of
them just worked if we were to ever move
away from typescript in the future we
could strip off the types and end up
with roughly the same JavaScript who
would have written otherwise
so one by one we documented considered
followed up and came up with solutions
to the questions and concerns raised it
was important to us to work with
detractors and hear out their concerns
we converted many of them to advocates
in the end and our proposal became
stronger from their feedback after
sufficiently addressing concerns we
surveyed all front-end engineers on
whether we should adopt typescript given
the positive response we had enough
evidence to move forward and the
proposal was approved from there we
gradually expanded adoption and at this
point we had completed the pilot phase
that was valuable for proving out
typescript and getting the foundation in
place we ironed out frictions early and
improved tooling and documentation so
later teams would have a smoother
on-ramp we have ongoing contact with the
typescript team and help surface issues
like prioritizing better handling of
default props as one example this phase
also grew our internal typescript
community most people had Airbnb don't
know typescript yet so this meant more
people could help and answer questions
next we moved into a beta status and
teams could opt into using it to help
onboard teams we created internal
documentation and a style guide and
hosted learning sessions we set up a
slack channel an internal Stack Overflow
tag at Google email group of github
group people could use on their PRS we
wanted to make sure people could get the
help they needed the final step is
graduating typescript to general
availability meaning it's stable and
everyone should start using it we're
actively approaching this at the moment
the remaining steps are solidifying
style guide documentation ramping up
internal education efforts and migrating
more code we're about 50% of teams using
typescript and 10% of the files in our
mono repo have been converted so far
using this gradual approach made for
smoother adoption if we've said from day
one that everybody should start using
typescript person after person would
have run into the same issues or had the
same questions instead we could figure
things out on the smaller scale and
carry forward and those answers would
carry forward as we expand it out
we've been exploring a couple options
for migrating our code to type scripts
our original migration strategy was a
JavaScript type script hybrid let's see
how this strategy works in the context
of our mono repo this is a simplified
version that I came up with by literally
going to airbnb.com and giving
reasonable names to the things I saw so
no company secrets here let's zoom in on
the homes project and see what it would
look like to convert it using the hybrid
strategy we added a typescript config
file and renamed individual files from
jst TS or JSX to TS x typescript errors
pop up and we proceeded to fix them an
awesome feature of typescript is that
not all code has to be converted before
it can compile and run the allow JSF
configuration option allows javascript
and typescript files to live
side-by-side so at this point we can
check in what we have so far and the
site still works we don't have to pause
development migrate the whole project
and then my and then do that first we
can migrate instead file by file we
repeat this process over time until the
whole project is migrated on the topic
of migration I wanted to take a brief
moment and share some tips we found
helpful the first is TS fixed me we
added a global type alias for typescript
any type which means something could be
anything
we called it TS fix me to indicate that
it should be revisited and fixed up
later on best practice is to avoid any
because it loses type safety but it can
be helpful during the migration process
the TS ignore comment silences the error
on the following line properly typing a
file might involve unraveling some deep
chain of dependent types we try to avoid
this by like converting leaf files first
but sometimes it's inevitable so TS
fixed me and TS ignore can help split
things up such that incremental work can
be checked in these are intended to be
temporary and we're planning on adding
type coverage tooling to help remove
them as we refine the types over time in
JSX we use prop types on a react
components for runtime type checking
when converting a JSX
to tsx we can either remove the prop
types in favour of a tight script type
or keep the prop types and add a type
script type in addition in our react
component library for example we wanted
to keep prop types so that JavaScript
consumers could still get runtime checks
but to avoid declaring a second type
that would need to be kept in sync with
those prop types we created a props type
utility that is able to derive the type
script type given the prop types and the
default props in this case the prop
types and default props get combined
into this final type if you're curious
how this works under the hood
I created a gist that you can check out
recently we've been experimenting with a
revised all in typescript migration
strategy so let's go back to that Holmes
project we were looking at before and
use The Awl end strategy instead to see
how it works we start off with all j/s
we convert everything over to TS get the
project compiling perhaps we use some
looser types than we'd like but we still
have type scripts strictest options turn
on and then we proceed to refine the
types over time removing the TS fix
means NTS ignores this has some
advantages over the hybrid strategy it's
easier to refine type I type rather than
file-by-file if you're developing a
feature and you only care about adding
one type it's a much lower barrier to
entry to just fix up that type in
isolation rather than having to convert
the whole file first fix up all the
errors and then add the type you care
about not having to rename the file also
means that it's easier to review
sometimes if a file is renamed in one
commit then changes are made in another
they show up separately in code review
and the reviewer has to piece together
what happens it also makes it clear what
types are missing type scripts inference
is powerful and we can leverage it for
large portions of a file some files
require a few to know TS fixed means in
order to in order to compile type script
can figure out the rest another is that
developers can use a consistent mental
model they don't have to contact switch
depending on what file extension they're
in like why can't I add a type here why
am I not getting compilations errors
there types can be added consumed and
type checked in all files
yeah that sounds great but how do we
migrate all the code code mods are a
powerful tool for large-scale code
modifications in their simplest form a
codemod could be a global find and
replace across a project you might have
done this in your editor before and
there are code mod libraries that do use
read exes but they are brittle because
they might break depending on subtle
code style variations alternatively we
can use an abstract syntax tree which is
something that the speaker's earlier
brought up to so this is the ast
representation of this code notice how
for every piece of code on the left it
has a corresponding node in the tree on
the right so just for fun say we wanted
to write a code mod that reverses all
the identifiers in our code we'd start
with our code as the input creating the
ast out of it modify that ast and emit
new source code out the power here is
that we are making this change
programmatically the alternative would
be editing each file to make the change
and this works fine if you only have a
handful but once it gets to be more like
thousand files the thought of manually
changing them gets really sad
Facebook's J's code shift is a popular
tool we use for code mods at Airbnb this
transform captures the modifications we
just made to that ast to reverse the
identifiers we find all nodes that
correspond to identify errs replace
those nodes with new ones with the name
reversed and then return the new source
code back out Missy Elliott would be
proud of us so we flip the m reversed it
I got laughs that's great I was debating
goes like Joy Division I do it
we took the code and we modded it found
the identifier slip the member stump is
your friend you oh yeah
a tool that cannot help you with your
rap skills but can help you with your
code mods is ast xplornet which Sean
pointed out earlier it has a source code
that transform and the output and an
interactive ast all in one place also I
just landed a definitely type here to
add types for Jaz code shift that makes
it easier to author code mods and type
scripts several patterns emerged while
migrating JavaScript code to typescript
we repeatedly moved static class
properties into the class body for react
components created a props type
annotated react lifecycle methods we
were encoded these as code mods so that
we can run them repeatedly over more
code and we package them up in the tool
called TS migrate the goal is to send a
JavaScript project in and get a
compiling typescript project out now you
you'd still need to find the types over
time but it gives you a baseline to work
from we applied this tool to our
internal shared react components library
which is used everywhere across the site
we had types for this in our internal
definitely typed but it was hard to keep
those up-to-date with the rapid
development of the shared react
components library so instead we wanted
to emit types directly from the source
so it was our first target for TS
migrate we converted over 30,000 lines
of code to typescript and instead of
devoting the whole team's time four
weeks to do this we could run our suite
of code mods and do it in minutes we use
the type information from prop types and
made use of TS fixme and we are
continuing to refine from this baseline
but even with this we generated
meaningful typescript declaration files
we can consume in other repos in case
that PR line count looks a bit scary
with the typescript compiler half
for visual regression testing and our
just test running in CI I felt confident
that my changes wouldn't break anything
and of course we made sure the site was
still working
no regressions whew we have since run TS
migrate in other places and we're
iterating on it and we're planning on
using it across more and more code we
plan to open source it so that you can
use it to migrate your code to thank you
for following along this journey with me
I'd like to leave you some key takeaways
that we can draw from this typescript
transition that apply more generally
effecting change at a large organization
can be a challenge
but strong evidence and addressing
questions and concerns make a compelling
case adopting change gradually helps
reduce friction and prove out the value
a clear migration path helps teams move
over to new patterns and tooling can
help expedite the transition I started
this work while on a product team
feeling dissatisfied with my tools when
I learned that there were others in the
company who also wanted to make this
change I partnered with them and carried
the initiative forward it's all too easy
to complain about things accept the
status quo positive change can come
about through actions of people who care
so I'd encourage you to pursue the
things that you're passionate about your
organization to make life better for you
and those around you
thank you all for listening and thank
you to everyone at Airbnb who
contributed to this effort
shout out to Joe and Mohsen who are in
the audience and miles and Portland's
and there are a bunch of other awesome
Airbnb engineers who would love to talk
to you I also have some typescript
stickers and some Balogh keychains for
the like the first 30 people that come
find me so just as an incentive yeah
thank you so much
[Applause]